foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
hearing day oh it's hearing day
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Thursday June 9th tonight
8 P.M Eastern the gavel goes down
and we will find out
exactly the evidence
that we've been waiting for for so long
we are here
at this day we are going to be
broadcasting an hour before the gavel
goes down on the on the Midas Touch
YouTube channel I am hosting the special
coverage of the January 6 Select
Committee hearing
tonight 7 PM Eastern the Gap will go
down at eight but we will have a
commentary an hour before
we have some great special guests this
great special commentators
we have Michael Cohen the my zealous
Brothers Michael popock and Karen
agnipolo from legal AF we have Lee
McGowan politics girl
David Bender we had the political
strategy strategist Adam Parker minko
they're all going to be here all of them
Texas Paul all you mind is mighty out
there no Texas Paul I think Texas Paul
is going to join us tonight
we will be talking an hour before the
hearing over on the Midas Touch YouTube
channel so make sure to go over there
and follow that link on the YouTube
channel subscribe to the link
make sure you follow over there
we all see be broadcasting from the
Midas touch Facebook page for all you
facebookers out there
we will be broadcasting there as well
so don't forget
to get your popcorn ready an hour in
advance
because the hearing starts at eight
Eastern
but we will start our coverage at 7 00
PM Eastern Time
so get your popcorn your candy your
beers ready you may need some beers for
this it sounds like we're going to get a
lot of new information that even the
public doesn't know and more than that
we're actually going to see the evidence
that we've heard about
one of the piece of evidence that I'm
looking forward to
is the testimony
of jivanka I don't know I don't know is
that how you say it Jared Kushner and
Ivanka Trump apparently part of their
testimony to the January 6 select
committee will be played during the
presentation the presentation seems to
be 90 minutes I bet they take a break
somewhere in between so we will probably
have commentary in between on the break
and we will actually after the hearings
over stick around after the hearing is
over
we are going to have commentary
afterwards from all your great
personalities that I just mentioned
and and more probably more to come on
who will be after the after party so
don't get too wasted during the hearing
don't don't drink too many beers until
the after party got it
I don't know I mean go ahead whatever
you want to do you want to be completely
wasted when you watch the after coverage
come join the live chat
drunk chat on the YouTubes
we would love to have you there and I
love having you here every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on the Tony
Michaels podcast simulcasting from the
Midas touch Facebook page again
two hours every single weekday
but these hearings are going to be
something special we're going to do the
special coverage we have our own live
feed that we're going to be working off
of
you will see the commentary from the
commentators I actually have Michael
popock coming on today
Michael popock we're gonna have a popoc
pop in he's gonna give us a little bit
of pregame I talked to Michael this
morning and Pope says that he has read
the 200 Page brief
um which he he's probably just a handful
of you that have actually read the whole
brief so he's going to give us a little
rundown of not just the very first
hearing but how the hearings as a
collective what they're really going to
tell us
and that's probably
more important than just one hearing
alone but tonight will be the big banger
the committee hired a big TV producer to
produce the the presentation tonight for
America to see the evidence to lay out
the evidence in a way that is easily
digestible
so that way the American people have a
chance to know exactly what happened on
January 6 when the Cheeto dusk kangaroo
coup attempt tried to overthrow our
government tried to take our
constitution away from us tried to rip
up and throw away our vote
and our decision our rights in this
country listen this is very important I
want everyone to understand this
because we make a lot of jokes about the
Cheeto dust kangaroo coup and Grandpa
poopy pants Donald Trump himself
and we poke fun and we goof around a lot
about Maga and Trump humpers
but here's the long and short of it and
why this matters
not just the January 6 select committee
and their hearings and the public
hearings and the evidence that they've
collected but also the Department of
Justice and believe you me
believe you me they are working hard
in the background
I know it doesn't seem like it I know it
feels like it's taking forever but they
are working on it trust me
we see a governor a candidate for
governor Michigan I believe a republican
Ryan Kelly I believe is I don't know who
this [ __ ] guy is
we're gonna find out though he's gonna
find out any
this [ __ ] is gonna find out
he has reached the find out phase of the
[ __ ] around Saga this Ryan Kelly
but this is why the January 6 select
hearings and the doj investigations
induce seditious conspiracy is so
important
let me lay it out to you very simple
if Donald Trump would have been
successful
in his attempt to overthrow our
Constitution and to subvert our vote and
our will the will of the people what
would stop him from overturning anything
else in our constitution or in our
democracy think about this for a second
think about your entire life what it
relies on
we don't just have a Federal
Constitution
we have state constitutions
we have County bylaws we have cities
City bylaws City councils we have state
funding Federal funding local funding
Public Schools
do you think that the thousands and
thousands of flights every day across
this country
do you think that they just they just
land and and take off and no one's there
to help them land and take off
so there's so they're safe
do you think all the food that comes
into the country do you think that is
just that's just that's just something
that happens
no one's there to help protect the
American people
let me tell you something
if Donald Trump would have overthrowed
our our vote he would have overthrown
our government
and made it to where he thought he could
do anything he want what would be to
stop him from saying you know
that Medicare Medicaid thing I don't
like to give that to disabled people
we're not going to make those payments
anymore
who would stop him who who do you think
would stop him you think the Republicans
would stop him
if he just decided to you know that
state really isn't part of our country
we're going to take their statehood away
they no longer have a constitution
they're part of this state now what's to
stop him
if he wanted to disband parts of the
military that weren't pledging
allegiance to him what would be to stop
him you say the Constitution Tony the
Constitution well he done [ __ ] on the
Constitution
if he would have overthrown our
government
I don't think people out there in this
country truly understand why this is so
[ __ ] important
this is important because he was going
to take away your vote and your way of
life
that's right your way of life would have
been crushed the schools you seniors
kids do and that may be gone the church
that you go to that may be gone your job
that may be gone you think the highway
departments would survive
not having a Federal Constitution think
about this for a second think about what
would happen
if we did not have the ideal alone of
the Federal Constitution being in place
if the idea was that this guy could just
[ __ ] all over it and get rid of the
Constitution because he doesn't like
democracy
because that's the long and the short of
it folks is the gqp does not like
democracy and the reason why is because
their ideas [ __ ] suck they [ __ ]
suck
and they know that we know that they
[ __ ] suck
and it's much easier to subvert
democracy than to get new ideas
they don't want new ideas they don't
want equality they don't want Equity
they don't they don't want lgbtq people
to have rights
they don't want liberals to have a say
they don't want people of other
religions to have a say in this country
only them and it sounds about white
doesn't it
they're fascist folks
and they they're not gonna stop
they're not going to stop trying to
overthrow our democracy here
we have to with our vote and our ballot
and the knowledge that we possess with
that vote and with that ballot is to
purge them out of our governments and
out of our policy making situations
we do not need a bunch of
insurrectionist a bunch of fascists
making policy in this country and
there's no better example than Florida
and Ron DeSantis that [ __ ] let's go
Brandon Nazi
Greg Abbott in Texas
and the list goes on and on
but accountability is going to be
knocking at the door in June
and it starts tonight with the truth
and the American people get to know and
get to see now will they watch is the
question
that's the real question here I don't
think there's a question rather Donald
Trump tried to overthrow our government
I don't I don't think that's a question
I don't think it's a question rather
Donald Trump wanted to be dictator and
King of the United States to protect
himself from prosecutions I don't think
that's the question
I think the question is will the
American people
look and watch what the truth is
whether they like it or not rather they
want to pay attention or not will they
that is the question
and that's what's up to us is to get the
get these these sound bites because
folks there's two things in this country
and Democrats have had a hard time
understanding this over the last three
decades and Republicans and especially
fascists understand this better than any
thank you
messaging is key
developing a narrative is key
Tony don't politicize this [ __ ] your
democracy your community your way of
life depends on politicizing this
because there's two things in this
country
there's policy
which is what government does
and there's politics
and they've always been better always
been better at playing the politics
but now's the time for us to politicize
this at every measure every moment every
second
over and over and over and over and over
again and repeat it and beat the drum
it's time for liberals it's time for
moderates it's time for Independence
it's time for people who are
pro-democracy to play politics and to
politicize every last [ __ ] millimeter
[ __ ] them
it's time grow a set of balls and let's
do this
let's fight for our democracy
Now's the Time
not last week not yesterday right
[ __ ] now
and I'm here for the fight every single
weekday
to yell and scream into the microphone
to give you the news
to give you the messaging that you need
and go out
and spread that messaging to your family
your friends your colleagues
hell Cynthia at the grocery store who
Rings up your milk and your bread
it's time
it's time these people know what the
[ __ ] happened even if they don't want to
pay attention or they don't really know
what to pay attention to
it's up to you
hell the entire country paid attention
to who Johnny Depp and Amber Heard was
for the last 6 000 years of what seems
like
we can use that model
use that model
to get this word out to show the
American people
that they tried to take away your way of
life your freedom
and all in the guise the patriotism
Mark Mark greike and mark first
we can do this and tonight it starts
with the January 6 select committee
opening their hearing
with the very first Prime Time hearing
which seems to be going to be a
90-minute presentation
and it will give us
a very very very good insight into the
evidence that is going to be laid out
over the month of June
for the evidence that the January 6th
select committee has collected that they
were able to make public because
remember folks just because this
information
is limited to the public in its form
because there's some things that the
select committee cannot put out in the
public the last thing the select
committee wants is to interrupt
or disrupt a doj investigation because
boy they're going there too I don't know
if you've seen the words
they arrested a republican candidate for
governor who's in the lead in Michigan
holy [ __ ] now I don't know if it's
because of the January 6th but this
guy's an insurrectionist
this Brian Kelly gay I don't know who he
is we're gonna find out and he's gonna
find out
he done [ __ ] around he's gonna find
out
apparently he's an insurrectionist that
might be the reason why he's arrested
apparently he is told people to tamper
with voting machines that might be
another reason hell there may be a whole
nother reason he's a republican so who
the [ __ ] can tell who can tell with
these goddamn Republicans they're
criming all over the place
it never stops with these [ __ ]
but we'll find out what why Ryan Kelly
was raided this morning and arrested by
the FBI
but at all all the insurrectionists it
seems to be caving in on them we saw
The Oath Keepers being charged with
seditious conspiracy three of them
plea pleading to charges and open court
claiming Brian Ulrich being one claimed
to the judge
that he was in a plan and a plot with
Stewart Rhodes the founder of The Oath
Keepers to not
have the election
go for it to make sure there was not a
transfer peaceful transfer of power
and now we see Enrique tario and his
lieutenants with the proud boys being
charged in a superseding indictment with
conditions seditious conspiracy
this conspiracy thing boy it's going to
be really tough if I could go back and
Rewind and I probably should to some of
my early episodes here on the Tony
Michaels podcast I said after the
January 6 elect committee or they have
to excuse me after the January 6th
Insurrection on January 6 2021 I said
there was going to be a lot of words
like conspiracy and superseding
indictments
and I said that I I could go pull the
clip
I said that in some of my early episodes
because that's that's what has happened
here this was well planned and I think
that's what we're gonna see tonight in
this first hearing and the the hearings
after the daytime hearings and the final
one which is also a prime time hearing
so don't miss that hearing tonight
don't miss it tonight
we start our coverage at 7 pm Eastern
over at the Midas Touch YouTube channel
you'll subscribe over there the link is
at the very top of their page
also you can make sure to follow us on
YouTube as well don't forget to follow
the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube as
well
very important you don't miss a thing
and also follow us on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod
we will be releasing the bonehead of the
week poll you know every Thursday we do
the bonehead of the week because on
Friday every single Friday in the second
hour of the show we break down your vote
for bonehead of the week and we will do
that tomorrow
in the second hour we will break down
bonette of the week so go vote at Tony
Michaels pod or on YouTube
come over to YouTube and get into the
Super Chat as well
now
if you do
want to download we are on Apple Spotify
Google all your favorite directories you
can download every single episode Monday
through Friday we also put up a best of
the week on Saturday
and Bone net of the week in and of
itself on Sunday so you get seven
episodes every single weekday over on
your favorite directory you can download
the Tony Michaels podcast but tonight
tonight is so special with the special
coverage
we're gonna hold we're gonna have we're
gonna have we're gonna have big names
big names the minus mighty No Texas Paul
we got politics girl Lee McGowan we got
Michael Cohen we got the my zealous
Brothers we got Adam Parker minko
we got a whole host we got Karen
ignipolo KFA we got Michael popock from
legal AF the legal AF team is gonna be
there giving you legal analysis we have
David Bender a political strategist
so many people are going to be joining
us tonight for these hearings
so please come watch the hour before
cook your popcorn pop your popcorn an
hour before get those beers ready or
wine coolers or wine or whatever the
hell you're drinking
get it ready beforehand we're going to
be starting an hour in advance
of the hearing because the hearing the
gavel drops at 8 pm Eastern and I would
bet that Benny Thompson starts the
moment
that the clock strikes eight
would be my guess
Vinnie Thompson
has started all his hearings right on
time so I would guess that that is going
to be the exact case tonight
that as soon as the clock turns to 8 PM
Eastern the gavel will come down but
join us an hour in advance over on the
Midas Touch YouTube Channel Please
Subscribe over there as well and follow
that link
set your reminders it's gonna be a party
it's gonna be a party
we're gonna have Michael popock here in
just a few minutes I'm not sure exactly
I think around the bottom of the hour I
think Michael bubox is going to come in
he's going to give us a little synopsis
of the 200 Page memo that the the select
committee has put up
um he's probably one of the handful of
people that that have read the thing
front to back
so I wanted to get his uh take on the
entire scope of the hearings
not just this one in particular because
we got more than just one hearing folks
this first one is going to be set the
tone but we have five more after that so
and we will be doing Special coverage of
every single one of those and announcing
them as they go along but the most
important thing to know tonight is to go
over the mind and such YouTube channel
and set your reminder for that link
there on YouTube
for the special coverage of the January
6 select hearings stick around we will
be right back right after these messages
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day I'm recurring
and it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show thanks for joining us
concerning Michael Buck yes
what a day it's gonna be what a day it's
gonna be I'm excited about this tonight
this uh hearing I've been waiting to
watch this hearing to see what's going
to come out of it well you know
I think
I'm most excited to hear the words
of Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump
and and the questions that the January
6th select committee anstin there's
something about that that just oh boy I
can't wait to hear them turn on that
[ __ ] can you because I think
they will I think they have I think they
will you know they're like ah we're
gonna go to Miami so that way it's a
quick boat ride to Cuba I don't know I
don't I don't know they bought a house
in in Florida they were out of there
they're getting the hell out of there
it's time to leave Washington as what he
said at some point I guess I don't know
Jared Kushner
hmm
I bet I bet Hunter Biden's lapped up is
going to be releasing a statement later
on about some of the emails that it
received from Jared Kushner I don't know
maybe maybe they're obsessed with Hunter
Biden's laptop by the way it's been
trending this morning of course on the
Tweety tweets and the journey Trends and
we're gonna go through the Tweety tweets
and trendy Trends here I think Gabe is
going to join us at the bottom of the
hour as he normally does and then popoc
at the top of the hour I think is what
he's is what he's thinking so we'll see
popock here in about 30 minutes yeah
Gabon will go through the Tweety tweets
and The Trinity Trends here uh with Gabe
Sanchez the co-host and executive
producer boy Gabe has worked hard on all
the artwork and all the production for
the tonight's hearing so don't forget to
thank Gabe and for all the for all the
artwork and everything that you'll see
tonight
um he's done a fantastic job he's worked
hard he's actually he's actually going
to be off-site into a undisclosed
location the night so if he joins us on
the show for part of the the commentary
which I think he will in the beginning
um you'll see him in a unfamiliar
location
but uh don't don't be scared it's not
because he's you know
um with Ryan Kelly or anything it's not
like he's been arrested you guys heard
this right this uh Republican in
Michigan has been arrested he's running
for governor he's apparently the front
runner
I mean it's hard to tell why he's been
arrested really probably but who knows
he's a republican I mean you know
criminals gonna crime that's how it
works let's start the countdown
laughs
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
up where we round up all the Tweety
tweets and the journey Trends here is
your
special coverage card of all the people
that will be joining us and I think
we're gonna have more than this this is
just the Midas media Network
folks that will be joining us tonight
for commentary we're gonna have Michael
popock on here in just a bit he Michael
popock with a popoc pop in is going to
join us in just a little bit
um probably at the top of the hour I
would imagine uh Gabe Sanchez should be
joining us here in a minute but we're
going to go through some Tweety tweets
and some trendy Trends here because
there is a lot of stuff happening this
morning not just not just the January
6th um Insurrection hearing but we also
have we also have uh at the top of the
list we got this Ryan Kelly story and
I'm sure Gabe will tell us a little more
Michigan candidate for governor Ryan
Kelly arrested by the FBI for January 6
involvement that's the story that the
MPR is going with so it looks like he's
that's what he has been arrested for
um now he'll probably be arraigned
within the day or two and I think he was
arrested at his home in Michigan so
they'll probably arraign him in Michigan
and then send him to DC where he will be
in front of a judge or they'll release
him on an ankle bracelet or something
like that and apparently this guy is the
the front runner I don't know the front
runner I guess I don't know
kind of funny though on the same day
that the Republicans are cheering that
your Fourth Amendment rights are are
taken away from you uh because you can't
see the feds for unlawful search and
seizure they're going to be bitching
that there was unlawful search and
seizure of Ryan Kelly
mark my words mark my words they'll be
saying it oh this is all a setup it's
all part of the blah blah blah and
they're ready to stop the scale or
blehem mother America First all kinds of
[ __ ]
hmm hashtag January 6 Committee hearing
is trending Diet Coke is trending
I bet Donald Trump is trying to figure
out how to keister Diet Coke at this
point maybe that's why it's trending I
don't know maybe he's trying to figure
out how to keister Big Macs and Diet
Coke he sees Ryan Kelly
uh being arrested the Michigan candidate
for governor and the Republican
candidate for governor arrested by the
FBI maybe maybe Trump's getting a little
nervous and that's why Diet Coke is
trending he's trying to figure out how
to keister as much as possible
you know it happens they they have some
Diet Coke probably on the commentary but
Big Macs probably do not reach the
commissary list
in lock up I'm sure
um we see scotus is trending at number
nine now you guys remember this story
yesterday where someone got you know
within a mile of Brett Kavanaugh with a
gun and now now they want to pass gun
control they want to pass gun control
because they're precious nominee their
precious pick they're bought and paid
for Supreme Court justice has been
threatened with a gun
look we've been yelling and screaming
about this forever dummies how about gun
control and people just crazy
[ __ ] just buying guns
and now all of a sudden all of a sudden
a bipartisan bill from the Senate led by
Mitch McConnell comes out that yeah we
should protect the Supreme Court Justice
[ __ ] those 19 kids in Uvalde to hell
with them [ __ ] damn who gives a [ __ ]
about them who cares about school
children
they can go [ __ ] themselves
Brett Kavanaugh he's bought and paid for
baby
and he's the one that's going to make
sure that those school children can get
slaughtered don't you know Jesus Christ
what's going on
so Mitch McConnell wanting to protect
Brett Kavanaugh and scotus they really
are a bunch of bunch of [ __ ] right I
mean I mean you take a look at the the
video of the girl talking about how she
had to spread blood all over her body to
play dead so he wouldn't [ __ ] murder
her
and here a guy gets within a certain
mile radius of Brett Kavanaugh with a
gun
and the Senate freaks the [ __ ] out and
they're willing to pass a bipartisan
Bill give me a [ __ ] break
not impressed I am not [ __ ] you Mitch
McConnell you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
won't protect our children but you'll
protect your bought and paid for Supreme
Court Justice hmm seems kind of fishy to
me I'm not saying don't protect the
Supreme Court Justice it's not what I'm
saying I'm saying protect all Americans
I don't care if they're NRA bought and
paid for or not
but it does seem fishy when 19 children
are slaughtered and they'll do nothing
but talk about back doors and dildos and
porn
but as soon as uh bought and paid for
NRA bought and paid board Supreme Court
Justice the federal Society
the fascist the rapist the Molester
the tear in his beer that is Brett
Kavanaugh
may just have an encounter with a weapon
oh my God we gotta [ __ ] we gotta do
we gotta make some legislative action
then
forget about the children being
slaughtered Marco Rubio's a dumb [ __ ] oh
how do you know that well he's trending
at number 13. and embarco Rubio's
trending it's because he's a dumb [ __ ]
what do you what do you what do you
think Gabe you think that's why he's
trending incidentally because he's done
100 Marco Rubio is never like oh
everyone's excited Marco Rubio said
something he said something worth worth
listening to Marco Rubio's Tritt no no
yeah it's the uh you know he was born on
the birth certificates at Marco Rubio
and then said I'm a dumb [ __ ] I'm a dumb
[ __ ] I'm just dumb dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
will he make uh bonehead of the week I
well he is I think maybe he will we're
gonna have to do we're gonna do bonehead
a little early though because yeah yeah
here's the thing do we do we establish
who the boneheads are we can't right
here right live with the audience the uh
we'll maybe we'll just do where the
audience can help us decide here does
the audience think Marco Rubio should be
bonehead of the week you you guys you
guys put in the chat there if you think
uh Marco dumb [ __ ] should be bonehead of
the week uh here I'll play the video if
you guys aren't aware of why he's
trending because of the some of the dumb
[ __ ] he said about the Select Committee
hearing tonight
um and then maybe you should decide here
we go pretty low well this was a real
Congressional hearing and not a kangaroo
court and not a circus and not a made
for TV production and an infomercial for
their political purposes those are the
questions they would be asking that's
exactly what they would be asking it
would be a review of why didn't Capitol
Police why didn't the sergeant-at-arms
take advantage of these resources that
were available that's right I love this
I love that he's blaming he's he's
blaming the sergeant in Arms from not
stopping Donald Trump from trying to
attempt a a Cheeto dust kangaroo coup
this is really rich that Marco Rubio is
blaming the sergeant-at-arms at the
Capitol
for not for not making sure that he
stopped Donald Trump and the Republicans
and The Oath Keepers and the proud Boys
in this big coordinated effort
with all the funds I'm sure that the
sergeant-at-armed has at his disposal
right you know forget about the National
Guard right forget about that forget
about forget about the Capitol Police
forget about forget about the D.C police
forget about all that forget about the
FBI forget about all that
forget about all those people that have
all those are a lot of things to forget
about right Marco Rubio once wants to
blame this on the sergeant in our God
damn you Sergeant you should have
stopped us Republicans from trying to
overthrow your government what the [ __ ]
is he talking about
he is he has got one of the most
punchable faces too by the way look at
this yeah yeah totally
I mean as As Trump called him you know
little Little Marco right he's like
sipping on his water very similar to how
Trump
maybe there's a pattern there I don't
know I don't know it's funny because
he's an Republican party Mark Marco used
to hate Trump he used to hate they all
hated Trump oh yeah until Trump got in
and then had the [ __ ] on him had the
dirt they were like okay actually what
we really meant was by hate
we met in love okay it was opposite day
every day during the campaign when we
said hate we really meant love ah these
weak [ __ ] such a weak piece of
[ __ ] to try to blame the
sergeant-at-arms for the Republican
party and Donald Trump
and his allies in the dark Maga let's go
Brandon Nazis trying to overthrow our
government so there's there's two others
I want to throw out there and see what
people say I was notified about uh oh
you're talking about for bonehead of the
week yeah okay okay so we'll keep we'll
keep Marco on the side here I'm already
I'm already starting a poll so I jotted
him down right
the the second that I was just informed
about this morning I think it was by uh
because I just saw it in the in the chat
we could put Ryan Kelly up there this
guy I don't know who that guy is but he
he seems like a [ __ ] bonehead he
might well I don't know if I don't know
if he's the bonehead yet okay I think he
might be I think he might be maybe he is
a bonehead he just might not be on okay
so there's there's uh John cornyn had a
tweet about oh well let's finish up the
Marco here and then we'll go to corn and
let's go to that [ __ ] bonehead let's
finish up Marco here let's listen you
would be focused on but they're not
gonna be focused on that this is a you
know I mean they move this thing to
prime time they hired a producer to put
it on this is not a fact-finding mission
this is a two-hour free documentary
sponsored by virtually every major
Network in America except for this you
know what's funny about that when he
says this is a documentary like does he
understand the words that he's saying no
does he get does he get what he's saying
because I I mean he's talking to an
audience just like oh them documentaries
that's fake news like oh them and he's
like every major News network besides
this one they're not a major new network
you're not a News Network work you're on
a propaganda machine Marco he's on an
entertainment show this is laughable at
best and I don't even know if it's
boneheaded if it's just pathetic maybe
that he's going on to suck off Sean
Hannity because here's the real news Fox
is carrying this coverage over on Fox
Business so for Marco Rubio to go over
on Fox News quote unquote and say oh
this is a sham and all the major news
networks are carrying it because it's
all the Sham and blah blah blah and fox
is actually going to carry it on their
business Channel because they can't play
it on Fox News Gabe and the reason why
is because the people who will be
hosting it are evidence
you're part of the [ __ ] evidence
that's why they can't carry it because
they were part of the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup they were part of the
attempt to overthrow our government we
we said we said it uh yesterday the day
before like imagine being on Fox news
live streaming the actual hearings and
then they throw your name into the mix
to say well actually uh Laura Ingraham
was texting Meadows during the
Insurrection telling him we need to get
this thing under control then you have
Sean Hannity also texting Meadows like
to get this stuff that would be on their
Airwaves in front of their you know uh
their their viewers would be
so I mean it would be shooting
themselves in the foot right I mean
that's what essentially would be they'd
be airing their own situation and then
them having to defend themselves on
public television oh hey maybe that
maybe maybe well that would be great
that would be a great TV I would
actually turn over to Fox News just to
watch that but they're not gonna do that
right one of uh off key because I
because one of the greatest moments in
Fox News history is when Barack Obama
beat Mitt Romney do you remember this
moment when they announced Barack Obama
one I flipped over to Fox News and Carl
Rose head was exploding and like no you
can't blah blah blah blah blah it was
fantastic that's probably a lot of
moments that are going to happen right
right but but let's finish little Margo
here and then we'll move to another
bonehead this one that's willing to give
it airtime the only good thing about it
is most Americans aren't going to watch
this garbage I mean people already know
what happened that day they're watching
the Justice it's not even one opposing
voice it's it's funny it's funny that
they say there's not one opposing voice
and the reason why is because all the
opposing voices were insurrectionists
like they're like oh Jim Jordan should
be on the committee and Nancy Pelosi is
like no [ __ ] you he's he's he's one of
the ones we're investigating you dumb
[ __ ] like the opposing voices
are people they are they I mean they are
all upset because they're like we wanted
to be on the community in in McCarthy
said we could be on the committee and
Paul she's like nah [ __ ] that noise uh
we're investigating you so we're not
gonna put you on the committee and then
you find out it's like oh oh yeah the
public now knows the reason why you
couldn't put someone on the committee
because there would be one a conflict of
interest because you're [ __ ] being
investigated you're the person of
interest they're not gonna let someone
who they're not it's like oh let me just
let the murderer onto the jury panel and
let them taint the the actual decision
that's made like you can't just have
someone go in and be like hey look guys
I know it looks really bad out there for
me okay I know it looks really like the
the evidence like
tldr I did do it I killed them uh but it
looks really bad I know I know it does
but just hear me out
I didn't do it let's think about that
like that's the reality they live in
where they're like [ __ ] we were involved
and we need to get on this Committee in
this panel
to make sure that we can know what's
coming up but also uh we can think of
what our strategy our narrative is to to
get a circumvent this and say how this
isn't real how this isn't true right and
that's why the generous six committee
has played things so close to their
chest it's because they don't want this
[ __ ] coming out they don't want it
leaking they don't want anyone to get a
heads up so that they could re-spin it
before it's able to come out well here's
the thing the other thing I think you
make a great point is because they want
the American people to hear it first
right they don't want they don't want it
to leak out and have arguments against
um like Bill Barr did with the Mueller
report because that's what that's what
Bill Barr did to the Mueller report yeah
is he he he did his rebuttal to the
Mueller report in advance which created
this narrative beforehand before it ever
released so it was it was there was lies
placed in in action before before the
truth was even out so that's why they
played closer you know the analogy
though that I would go with here is it
would almost be like
putting Al Qaeda on the 911 Commission
to investigate
to investigate the planes being flown in
the buildings right here that's that's
probably a good comparison you know
again you know it's like letting the you
know letting the arsonists in and saying
guys look I know I've got this gasoline
and these matches on me right now
but and I know that I was videotaped and
I even said hey it's me I'm [ __ ]
lighting the fire right now but just
give me a second right I can tell you
how it's not me
right well speaking of telling people
how it's not something I'm sure John
cornyn is going to give us a a good run
down here the Washington Post posted a
headline here it says man with a weapon
detained near Brett Kavanaugh's home I
love that near yeah he was he was two
streets of Jason like I don't know where
he actually was right but he was
adjacent to the house near the house
wasn't in the house right probably
wasn't even here and then when they say
near like it's probably like he wasn't
actually I mean what is near is near
like within a mile
right that's what I'm saying it's like
yeah like I don't know what their metric
or their distance is like is near a
blockage I just I just find it really
funny that that they caught this guy
near Brett Kavanaugh's home and he
allegedly told police he wanted to kill
the Supreme Court Justice you know there
was a there was a shooter down in Uvalde
Texas that was near a gun store when he
turned 18. he was near a credit card and
they nearly they nearly gave him more
than 1700 rounds and two weapons right
and then he got near a school with those
weapons and then he went in and nearly
got close enough to people to blow their
[ __ ] heads off but they won't do a
goddamn thing about that but I'm sure
John Corden has a great take here on
some regulations that he would like to
have happen because there was a a weapon
near yeah Brett Kavanaugh his buttons
and who knows what the weapon was was it
a knife I don't know like a bully Club
you know well some are some are saying
you in a handgun I don't know we don't
know that at this point I mean that's
pure speculation but I mean if he did
have a gun I'm not I'm not make I want
to make sure that that guy can't get a
gun right right exactly like most people
in this country are they want to make
sure you have a background this is the
moment when we all come to the an
agreement
one person should not have a gun to
approach a sitting Supreme Court Justice
number to kill them we agree right okay
great now let's apply that same logic
and protection right everyone else can't
actually defend themselves right like
here's John cornyn I'm sure he's going
to do a bang-up job here of just of
selling the argument that you're trying
to make he says speaker Pelosi I implore
you please pass my skoda's security bill
I I find it hilarious that the the one
day not 24 hours after they arrest a guy
that's near Brett Kavanaugh that may be
trying to kill him he is imploring
speaker Pelosi to pass his skoda
security bill that's how fast they wrote
this thing every day that's how fast
they were when they were like oh these
guys are picketing outside this is not
fair I wrote on sidewalk with chalk this
is ridiculous he says John cornyn says
every day they don't the threat to the
justices grow really that's kind of
funny
for tragedy becomes more likely and
house Democrats achieve a new Apex a
political dysfunction really get the
[ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] this is
the same [ __ ] by the way that
everyone is relying on to make sure that
some some sort of gun reform happens in
the Senate get the [ __ ] out of here with
this [ __ ] also political political
dysfunction right political dysfunction
I mean it sounds pretty close to
political discourse which is kind of the
thing that they is that like Central
Anarchy it's kind of like sexual Anarchy
uh but you know political discourse it's
just regular political discourse it was
just it was just a tour it was just
nowhere no one better no one better to
know what political dysfunction is than
Senator John cornyn from Texas really
honestly I mean he's probably an expert
on political dysfunction yeah they know
it when they see it so we've got we've
got got two people on the board right
now
and we've got Corning okay now the third
there are four on the list right now so
I think we'll go from the four unless
somebody else in the in the comments
suggests two other people or another
person but the next person I've got on
the list are also related to Kavanaugh
is Kevin McCarthy it's just the tweet
that you sent me yeah yeah the the okay
okay the second one there okay well
let's let's because the third one is
going to be bringing up scalise
obviously he's gonna make well obvious
obviously Steve scalise yesterday
comparing comparing uh not Banning
blanes after 9 11 this [ __ ] bonehead
holy [ __ ] and you know there's gonna
probably be even more boneheads as we
tick on through the day because they're
gonna have really bad takes but right
let's go to uh whoa look at that
temperature Evan McCarthy really looks
like he's pissed off here he must be
manned he must be mad that the evidence
is going to show that he was complicit
in the Cheeto dust kangaroo that's right
yes here let's listen how many times do
they have to be threatened how many
people have to be arrested is he talking
about school children being slaughtered
in Uvalde it really sounds like to me he
it sounds like to me he's so outraged
because I was outraged about children
yeah actually being killed like their
[ __ ] heads blown off decapitated Gabe
there were parents that had to identify
their [ __ ] children with their shoes
I bet that's what he's mad about I
almost can probably not though that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] let's listen with
a gun outside their home
what would have happened had he not
called 911. he didn't just have a gun
wait what what is that how he wait he
calls nine one one nine eleven did he
just did he just do that
yeah he called he totally did called
911. let's back it up well let's back it
up I gotta re-listen this what would
have happened had he not called 911 he
totally said is that something look I I
okay I'm just gonna say maybe that's
something they say down in Bakersfield
okay right maybe maybe it's that [ __ ]
anywhere else in California or Chicago
or any other state I've never heard it
that way I mean I've heard 911 is like
September 11th right yeah but it's nine
nine emergency phone calls 9 11. what
the what the [ __ ] this is weird Okay
let's let's continue here with
mr91191 and I'm not sure he didn't just
have a gun
get zip ties oh my God Gabe can you
imagine can you imagine if someone came
near public officials with zip ties can
you even [ __ ] imagine the outrage
dude this guy this guy sounds like a
really honestly if he had zip ties
though he sounds like a patriot he
sounds like a tourist right well I mean
he's gonna sound like an American
Patriot that's also a tourist you know
right I mean that's what happened you
know just political discourse right I
mean when you have zip ties near
government officials it's that's your
tourist right right American Patriots
Maga Patriots this [ __ ] [ __ ]
but somehow you want to leave
what this bill could be on the how many
times do they have to be threatened how
many people have I want to listen to it
again with a gun outside their home with
a gun outside their home or their school
or maybe their grocery store maybe their
Church Kevin McCarthy maybe inside their
home yeah that could be someone could
actually come inside the school and just
start mowing people down like maybe not
just with a handgun right maybe you
should be an AR-15 maybe you should be
[ __ ] outraged about that this is
really [ __ ] gross this is really fake
outrage here yep from these people about
this scotus and the reason why is
because the federal society's calling up
going hey man you got to protect our guy
he's going to get rid of abortion he's
going to make sure that we have plenty
of guns to murder children in schools
okay we can't have him murdered by a gun
Jesus Christ can you [ __ ] imagine
what would happen uh
this is absolutely [ __ ] gross yeah he
that he definitely needs to be on
bonehead so I mean I know I've got I've
got Kevin McCarthy and Steve scalise now
it comes down to who the final person is
gonna be
well what what does the audience think
here let's go to some of the comments
this is how the sausage is made this is
now normally me and Gabe are texting
back and forth yeah send the video like
why is he the moned who is this guy
there's a lot of thought that goes
there's some thought that goes into this
well sometimes it's just like ah these
three are trending and they're [ __ ]
dumb yeah these guys like sometimes
we're like we don't even know why we
just know they're like when Matt dance
Marjorie Taylor green or bobert is
trending we're like Yep they're
boneheads yeah that's pretty easy to bet
like you're like innate innate feeling
you know right which Matt Getz is
trending yeah yeah right which
which also he could also be on there it
could be for his comments that he made
about oh you know what he's actually a
[ __ ] that should be on bonehead
because of his comments about
um
uh about uh raskin's son
oh yeah yeah he said something about uh
I think I got it here not doing his job
let me see if I can yeah all right here
here it is let's now he's he's on he's
on uh foot greens podcast here mgg live
you know I think they're setting up to
not be Congress people what do you think
I think oh I think what they're doing
every one of these people are setting
themselves up for their own podcasts and
shows and to make an uh a passive income
because they know yeah they got a grift
well here's the thing is is I actually
think if you listen to Benny Thompson's
statements yesterday and I'll actually
go to that tweet from the January 6th
select committee uh if you can find that
for me uh of his statement yesterday so
we can pull that quote up Benny Thompson
basically said hey uh we're gonna make
sure the results of this Select
Committee hearing we're going to make
sure the Insurrection never happens
again and I think what he means is
they're going to expel some members of
Congress I think there's going to be a
list of Congress people that are going
to go on expulsion list and the house is
going to vote for that expulsion list
um now rather there's senators in the
Senate that get voted on but I know
there's probably going to be a handful
of people in the house Paul's those are
um more than likely chip Roy these
[ __ ] idiots here on the screen and
they're probably going to be on the list
of of expulsions some of the ones that
we're giving tours of the Capitol to
make sure you know where uh where
clyburn's office were where Nancy
Pelosi's office was
um some of these things are are going to
come out and I think there's going to be
expulsion lists um that's why they're
holding a lot of this information close
to the chest here that's why and these
people are expecting it like Matt gatz
and RJ Taylor green they expect to be
expelled from Congress they know they're
not going to be Congress people anymore
so they got to do something they got to
do something so they're going to come
they're going to come into the podcast
world and yelling scream into a
microphone that's what they do anyways
that's what they should have done they
should have never really ran for
congress yeah they should have just been
commentators because they are you need
you need a platform to project yourself
forward forward so that people are like
oh yeah it's that dumb [ __ ] right well
you know that may be let's listen to
dumb [ __ ] and dumb [ __ ] junior here
let's listen what I worry about with
Raskin in all seriousness you know um
when people
encounter trauma you mean like when you
um when you take underage people across
state lines yeah and you pay for venmo
um with the venmo to buy for for things
that are labeled as ice cream salads and
stuff and you give them drugs and
parties you know and you you you you
probably rate them sad story rape you
know it's a trauma like that is that
what you're talking about fake IDs for
those underage people or you joke about
how you did those things you know right
just yeah maybe that kind of trauma you
[ __ ] idiot they often associate a lot
of the other things around that trauma
with it even if they don't naturally or
or even rationally associate maybe so
and what I what I worry about for the
Congress I love how he's trying to make
it like oh I'm really concerned about
Jamie Ramsey I'm really I want to I want
to pretend to have empathy here as a
psychologist I did take psych 101 or at
least I read my girlfriend's psych 101
book
um you know but what I did learn is that
trauma is very
it's traumatic trauma is very traumatic
very traumatic it's very uh influential
in the rest of your life and then
Marjorie Taylor Green's like yeah yeah
whatever yeah whatever [ __ ] him [ __ ]
[ __ ] I'm glad that his son killed
himself is basically what she says right
I mean ah good good [ __ ] him is
basically what she says listening and
for for uh Jamie Raskin you know no one
would ever want to lose a child
particularly uh to Suicide of course not
as a human oh my God Jesus Christ she's
so [ __ ] gross of course not
meanwhile she's like let me get that gun
and go shoot some kids like that bang
bang bang liberals bad if you be scared
liberals of my big gun right
like we our hearts go out to him but
yeah I think that he takes that trauma
and he Associates it now with his work
in the Congress to such an inner woven
way that he's unable to kind of do the
Congressional experience out congression
does that include Like Cocaine sex
orgies or I I don't know can you do can
you go back like maybe like 10 seconds
maybe in five seconds it's yeah right
there watch Marjorie Taylor Green's
response with her head she does this
like pondering like I'm let me put my
glasses on um so she like she like does
the whole I need to look like I'm
thinking things yep watch okay let's
watch it's it now with his work in the
Congress to such such an interwoven way
that he's unable to kind of do the
Congressional experience she no no I
think what she's trying to do is figure
out what the hell interwoven me oh she's
like she's like what does that look at
me what is that she's like is that like
a soup or is that is that like a
gazpacho type soup or is that what is
that maybe maybe you put it in a peach
tree dish I don't know yeah
you're growing in a peach tree dish and
then you put it in your gazpacho uh
bully soup you know [ __ ] let's
oh if we can bear through it let's
listen to this outside of the just the
dungeon of that personal trauma and I
think it makes him look at it at
everything and these very like dark and
severe ways where you know we try to
come to the job really to uplift people
to we're here to serve the people well
and we we love this country out of a
sense of of grievance or hatred we love
America we love it and we want to
vindicate the rights of our citizens and
we want to Champion their causes and to
battle their dislikes but I think for
Jamie you're asking it's it's really
like his service in the Congress has
almost become like inextricably uh
attached to this this sad personal
trauma he's had and I think it does
cloud his judgment uh and we could see
that forget about the cooking sex orgies
forget about this let's not talk about
that also let's not he's like you know
he comes in here and he Associates and
stuff with very dark stuff is a not that
the [ __ ] January 6th Insurrection
wasn't [ __ ] dark like the the people
were chanting hang Mike Pence they
[ __ ] designed built broke down
transported and rebuilt [ __ ] Gallows
right now here's the other thing too
about Mike Pence and I don't know if
we'll hear from Mike Pence we're
supposed to hear from Mark short at some
point during these hearings but what I
really want to find out especially for
Mark short is why Pence wouldn't go with
the Secret Service yeah
that's that's really [ __ ] well I mean
his uh his chief of staff was was warned
you know about this and you know
forwarded that warning of like
might not be so safe you know it's like
[ __ ] dude that's the world we live in
well yeah they were in a parking garage
and they were debating even Mark short
The Story Goes and hopefully we'll find
this out from Mark short himself The
Story Goes that Mark Shores like no we
can't trust the Secret Service like
think about this the people who were who
were given the duty to protect the vice
president the vice president his chief
of staff are standing in a parking
garage and going no we're not going to
leave because we can't trust the people
that were that are supposed to be I
swore no to protect us we can't trust
them at this point because someone's
trying to sort the Constitution
someone's trying to overthrow the
government and they knew who it was
right they knew who it was they'd been
pressuring Mike Pence for [ __ ] weeks
and weeks and weeks pressuring him to do
something that he did not have the power
to do
it's absolutely batshit crazy but you
know forget about that the trauma that
Jamie Raskin
you know and really honestly to to to
Really downplay the trauma that it would
be for a [ __ ] parent to lose their
child to suicide is gross on these two
parts not only that to [ __ ] talk
about it and blame their problem that
they're gonna be held accountable by
Jamie Raskin on because his child
committed suicide you people are [ __ ]
vile and gross but you think you think
the reason why you're going to be held
accountable
is because Jamie raskin's child
committed suicide you people are [ __ ]
gross this is grosser than some of the
bathroom genitalia stuff this is really
[ __ ] gross darkness and that pain
yeah manifest on on Thursday in a way
that's not particularly relevant to the
challenges that we've talked about but
that might be like deeply relevant to to
what he's going through and yeah so
they're terrified of what Jamie rants
yeah they're like hey as a concerned
person parent or just someone who deals
with minors I could totally see how this
is relatable to my life right I'm just
gonna quickly make it about me right
right because Thursday you're going to
hear a lot about me oh yeah you're gonna
hear a lot about me a lot of people are
going to say stuff about me and I as a
concerned representative I'm just here
to uplift people and make people happy
you know vindicate the rights of like
what the [ __ ] well also word vomit salad
that's going on there are just like I'm
just going to say a bunch of stuff not
really say stuff but at the same time
I'm going to down and denigrate
Raskin and the loss of his son
to justify
why you could totally dismiss this whole
hearing and say that it's I was actually
out of the the turmoil and the pain that
Raskin was experiencing and he just took
it out on us it was unfair he just took
out this unwanted unnecessary anger
because because he had trauma right this
is really ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous so I'm gonna I feel like the
top three here yeah okay are Kevin
McCarthy yeah Steve scalise and Matt
Gates okay well that that might be the
top uh but I got some more here for you
oh god oh Mike Lee Mike Lee is um
disputing but I got a great tweet here
by on John fugle saying
um about Mike Lee and Ted Cruz now Mike
Lee is disputing that he had anything to
do with the plot to overturn the
Constitution of the United States right
yeah not to commit a coup but apparently
there's some court documents out there
that dispute that and I would show those
court documents but this picture is way
better
um my favorite pick of Mike Mike Lee and
Ted Cruz I like when two guys oppose gay
marriage go red shop shopping together
this is [ __ ] hilarious you gotta see
this God yeah these two look at this
look at this what the [ __ ] oh damn they
definitely it's weird this is a rug
people use I don't know they're like the
office building because it just goes on
the wall what this feels like this is
this feels like this is at a Senate
Office Building because it looks like
it's an office building oh so their
taxpayers paid for this I don't know but
here's the thing I'm gonna go with that
literally literally this rug was I don't
know Lay It lying around I don't know
are tiring you know I'm trying to
tigering I mean lay with the stripes you
know what they say I don't even know but
I can't but the point is and if you're
listening this on the directories you
definitely need to come over and at
least fast forward to this point yeah in
the show because you got to see this
picture of Ted Cruz and Mike Lee taking
a knee I thought they were against
taking the name they are against taking
these but it's only it's only when
you're protesting cops killing black
people that's when they're against it
when it's to take a picture of a weird
ass rug of a tiger
do you think they paid a hunter to get
it and then they shot it Like Donald
Trump Jr or do you think that they just
paid Donald Trump Jr to bring it back
from his coke uh fueled kind of hunt
right but but it's in an office and
they're like oh this is great let's take
a picture I don't understand like like
was someone walking around out in the
hallway with this on and they're like ah
bring this in here and we want to take a
picture it also kind of looks like
something you would put on to wear like
it'd be something that someone would
wear like like an insurrectionist like
the Buffalo Shaman the the chewing on
Buffalo yeah it seems like something you
know he puts the head on and then he
goes into the chambers maybe this was
maybe this was designed to be either
Mike Lee's or Ted Cruz's Insurrection
costume you know once they overturn the
government and the the Buffalo Shaman
was the speaker of the house they wanted
you know they put on majority of the
Senate right exactly what it is and
they're just cheering out over I don't
know but apparently apparently there's
some court documents that shows that
Mike Lee may have actually been uh part
of the plot to overturn the government
but this picture is way better yeah way
better for the Tony Michaels podcast as
far as evidence come on all right so I'm
gonna I'm gonna go with the Kevin
McCarthy Steve scalise and Matt Gates
okay is it is it is that the final is it
the final work that's the final three
those three people are pretty [ __ ]
disgusting well who are now who's here
once we do this we could very well find
someone later on that that has a
dishonorable mention or an alpha cook
it could be it could be all right um I'm
gonna I'm gonna get it okay I'm gonna
tweet it go ahead and tweet it and then
I'll delete it and then I'll put it on
YouTube
um here in a bit for you guys to vote on
YouTube all you YouTubers out there did
you did you see um this Ryan Kelly story
I haven't really investigated much yeah
yeah yeah other than it does it does
confirm now because I think you tweeted
something about why was he um I gave
three different options yeah it could
also be something completely different
well the three there were his
involvement at the Capitol on January
6th then
he his connection I mean his uh people
in his district wanted to remove him
from whatever uh position he was in
because of his involvement with militia
groups and then in January of 2022 so
wait he he is an elected official is
that he it's yeah let me find out
exactly what his his level is it's
something very local if I remember
correctly I guess
um but it's saying here in this in NPR
uh article that he was arrested for his
January 6 involvement so it seems like
there's a sealed indictment somewhere
that the media knows about that there's
a sealed indictment somewhere with the
January 6 involvement which they would
unsealed to right arrest him and then
arraign him and actually we're gonna
have I'm hoping popoc joins us here in
just a few minutes and maybe we can ask
him kind of the process of this but um
um the January 6 News just cannot stop
dropping here
um you know and then the right wing is
going to go oh this is all plot this is
all plot for the new station and the
fake news and the left to create a
narrative around January 6 that we were
trying to beat Traders and terrorists
and trying to overt that's because
that's what it was right the other one
was of course he was trying to you know
I think in Jan January 2022 he was on
the record telling people uh uh
people who are overseeing and running
the the voting machines
to manipulate the votes right right
right well and and that's so there's a
few there were a few things obviously
the first one I was imagining was like
his involvement with January 6 and I
said you know or it's something
completely different that we don't know
about
so feel free to take your pick you know
see here's already a [ __ ] [ __ ] take from
the fascist Jesse Kelly
the most dangerous thing happening in
America today oh the most dangerous
thing not like hey you know 19 children
being slaughtered yeah okay the most
dangerous thing happening in America day
is the full weaponization of the
administrative State against enemies of
the democratic party nothing else comes
close break the FBI into a thousand
pieces and shatter it in to the wins
okay so this is kind of funny Jesse
Kelly is tweeting this because the same
time that Jesse Kelly is tweeting this
the the Supreme Court Justices that he
loves that are bought and paid for that
are going to overturn Roe v Wade and
take your rights away took away your
Fourth Amendment right
to to unlawful search and seizure you
cannot you cannot and and better agents
cannot be sued at this point as the way
it looks on that decision
and for unlawful search and seizure
which is your Fourth Amendment right
that you do not have to participate in
unlawful search and seizure and if you
do whether you have the right to sue
them and Jesse Kelly is saying the exact
opposite here because a republican was
arrested right
so he so you know I'm just saying Kelly
might find his way onto the final yeah
list for tomorrow your Tweet sucks
as more details come out
and you know whatever happens tonight
who knows who knows
who's gonna be on the dishonorable
mention in the alpha Cup by tomorrow
morning
because it's anyone's game at this point
yeah well I mean um here looks like
criminal complaint against uh Ron has it
here
um
this is Criminal complaint against Ryan
Kelly currently the Front Runners
because he is the front runner I think
with like 19 is what I read and of
course all those people are going to be
like this is unjust you're gonna not
gonna take the front runner out of this
competition or this this race uh for
governor and it's like well the guy did
try to
overthrow the government so it's like so
this is the criminal complaint
um and it looks like the one that they
used
um that the magistrate used here for the
arrest warrant
um to arrest
and to search uh Ryan Kelly's home this
is where it came out because this is
from uh six seven which would have been
Tuesday is when the the magistrate
offered this complaint with a restaurant
and to be authorized now again it
probably was just unsealed this morning
when they arrested him and popoc's going
to be joining us here in a few minutes
maybe we can ask him about this I have
some questions about the uh the 200
pages and the hearings that's going to
happen tonight now we are going to have
some hearing speaking of Ryan Kelly
participating in the Insurrection we're
going to find out some information
tonight in these hearings I believe it's
going to be a banger Gabe oh yeah not
only that we got an hour's worth of
coverage beforehand before the hearing
tonight so the hearing gavels down at
eight uh Eastern 8 P.M Eastern we're
going to start at 7 p.m Eastern we're
gonna have all kinds of legal analysis
we're going to have political
strategists political commentators
coming in and giving their take on what
the January 6th select committee is
going to say what they think is going to
come out of this presentation because in
this first hearing we're going to see a
really well-produced presentation for
the American people to actually look at
the evidence
that the January 6 elect committee has
gathered and I think I think Vox news is
like oh look a bunch of Liberals are
making it into a documentary like yeah
well I mean if you want to make it to
where the American people actually see
the evidence it's probably a good idea
to make it to where it's I easily easily
digestible I mean we paid a lot of money
for them to collect this evidence about
how you try to overthrow our vote it
would be a good idea to make sure that
we can see it that that something that
makes it consumable so yeah they are
going to produce this thing and tonight
we're going to see it again our coverage
starts on the Midas Touch YouTube
channel at 7 00 PM Eastern
and don't miss it you're not not going
to want to miss the first hour before
the hearing and then I'm sure if there's
a Break
um which I'm sure they'll have a break
they usually have a break during these
hearings we will actually have more
commentary during the break and then
follow up afterwards don't get too
wasted I know you're going to get your
popcorn and you're going to have your
beer your wine whatever you're going to
be drinking maybe you should play a
drinking game every time they see
Insurrection but don't get too wasted
because at the end of the hearing we're
going to follow up with coverage and
we're going to continue the commentary
after the fact the great news about the
commentary after the hearing is we will
know what the hearings what they said
that will be after the fact that history
will be made
so will we be talking in the in the in
the hour after or more than the hour
after because really I plan on going an
hour after but if we have to go longer
if there's more relevant commentary uh
based on what they say in the evidence
that's there if we have enough to break
down because there might be a lot of
stuff to break down we will continue
that coverage afterwards even over an
hour so make sure to go over the Midas
Touch YouTube channel uh find that link
it's at the very top for the hearing
tonight that starts at our coverage
starts at 7 pm Eastern Standard Time
um that is four o'clock out on the
Pacific coast right
mm-hmm so four o'clock Pacific
seven o'clock Eastern do not miss it go
to the uh you might as such YouTube
channel you can also watch another minus
Facebook page right
um as well if you're on the books of
face and you want to watch it over there
so either on Facebook or the YouTube
channel but really go to the YouTube
channel because you you'll be able to
participate in the live chat I'm sure
some of our guests will be in the live
chat
um as as the hearing is going on so if
you want to hear from some of those
people speaking speaking of one of our
commentators in the live chat and
possibly uh someone who will continue
the coverage with us not just with this
first hearing but continue hearings now
I talked to Michael popock this morning
Gabe and he was telling me about a 200
Page uh report that was uh about the
hearings and he's he said he's read
every single little word
which is crazy just by the January 6th
committee that's right that's right so
he's read every word all 200 pages and
so I wanted to have him on this morning
and I think he was in the green room but
he's out there he must be having
difficulties
um I was I almost clicked the popoc pop
and uh chime you know preemptively done
yeah don't do it but he he had he must
be he must be having uh audio video
trouble there I'm not sure but um but I
wanted to bring Pope back on to tell us
about this uh 200-page report but also I
want him to give us a like a 50 000 foot
view of what all these hearings about
because tonight is the first hearing
right and it's a very important moment
but more importantly there's five more
hearings after right right right right
so as much information as we're gonna
get tonight we're actually going to get
more information from those coming
hearings and we're going to stream every
single one of those I do want to tell
the audience during the daytime hearings
our show that's the time for our show
know so we will We and we're trying to
work out how this will work but I think
during the time of our show we will
actually broadcast from our YouTube and
the Midas and I'm not sure how this is
all going to work but we'll figure it
out I think I think we get uh I think we
get our guy busy good I don't know give
us a thumbs up if you're good over there
uh okay he says he's good I I definitely
want to hear about this 200 Page report
so let's yeah let's bring in popock
Michael popock how are you I'm I'm doing
great how are you guys doing okay
fantastic doing fantastic so uh you
sound like you're it looks like you're
having a little trouble with your video
or something there no I couldn't hear
you oh I see technology you can hear me
now you can hear me now though great
Michael popock welcome thank you for
joining us and you're going to join us
tonight for some of the commentaries
yeah um during the hearing but you if
you were telling me this morning about a
200 Page reporter or something tell us
about that look oh wow in a binder it's
oh my god wow wow holy look at it I I am
probably the only person that's going to
be commentating with you tonight that
has read this you were probably a
handful of people in this entire country
get that from someone or did you go to
Kinkos and like get it in a binder and
everything no I have a day job but I had
an assistant that helped us that printed
and found it for me okay but um a little
known a little-known fact and thank you
again for having me on the show we are
I'm gonna be one of several overall
legal analysts that are going to join
you you have all sorts of political
commentators and strategists and things
but I think
Karen Friedman agnifolo Ben mysalis and
I and and to a certain extent Michael
Cohen you know he is he is a lawyer or
was a lawyer
um you know bring sort of an angle of
attack in listening and dissecting the
Jan six hearing uh with tonight's
kickoff
um session with the road map of of what
they're going to present over the eight
or nine sessions a couple of live
Witnesses you know and basically you
know setting the stage for all of the
gavel to gavel coverage that Gen 6
committee is going to be embarking on
and then we're going to be there pre and
post providing our analysis and you know
we've all been there from the very
beginning
some of the facts we've heard before
that we're going to hear tonight many of
these facts at least as they're being
put together and presented we've never
heard before
and they and that's on purpose you know
the the John 6 committee was very good
at being you know
um leak proof
that we heard what they wanted us to
hear when they went to morning Sunday
morning shows when they when they of
course had to go to court on subpoenas
when they had to file documents with
judge Carter in California we have a
good sense of sort of of where we are
but that's the tip of the iceberg most
of what they're going to be presenting
and the bombshell information that
they're going to be presenting about
Trump The Conspiracy to overthrow the
country it goes well beyond what
happened on Jan 6. for people that have
slept under a rock for the last year and
they think the Jan 6 committee is just
going to be talking about the tick tock
from 1 pm until 6 p.m on Jan 6 and the
aftermath that is not what the Jan 6
committee is going to talk about that
was one tool in the toolbox that Trump
used to try to overthrow the election
and to try to cling to power in a
seditious conspiracy and all of that
starting well before well before
election day all the way until John 6
and Beyond is what the focus of the Jan
6 committee is going to be and so I
think we're going to be shocked now as a
preview for those legal nerds out there
the Brookings Institute
that Think Tank has gone through and
done their own analysis both of publicly
available information and other
information apparently that was shared
with the Brookings Institute by the Jan
6 committee they issued a 250 page
report two days ago which is a guide to
the Gen six hearings and the questions
of criminality so of course I was eating
this up like catnip most of this I had
seen or heard before but never laid out
in the timeline of events and I thought
the most interesting thing
um Tony if you your takeaway from having
been a commentator all this time who
would you think are the lead
co-conspirators that the Gen 6 committee
and the Brookings Institute focused on
for the criminal conspiracy if you had
to name them who would they be well I
haven't read the report so
um not just from your own watching over
the years well my audience knows that
that I actually think there's a lot to
uh The Oath Keepers the five Oath
Keepers and the five proud boys being
charged with seditious conspiracy and
there's a guy we like to call him
stodger Roan on this show
um that's who we that's what we like
that you know stodger Roan there's this
guy this character who is associated
with the proud boys and The Oath Keepers
on that day they met in a parking garage
it seemed like there was a stash of
weapons across the Potomac um they were
waiting on a call for martial law it
really seems like the guys who were
charged with seditious conspiracy the
brown boys and The Oath Keepers who were
surrounded by Dodger Roan as we call him
here now some people know him as Roger
Stone I think I think him having such a
gross relationship with the Cheeto dust
mobster the former guy the grandpa poopy
pants Donald Trump himself having such a
personal relationship with him I almost
believe that maybe that was maybe a back
Channel I don't know if we'll see that
or not and I don't know if the if this
January 6th select committee is going to
focus on him but I damn sure well I I
damn sure bet that The Oath Keepers and
the proud boys are going to be a large
part of this evidence well you're right
about that the proud boys are going to
be front and center even tonight the
fact that in the first session in the
opening session in the opening statement
one of two witnesses one's going to be a
capital police officer who was horribly
injured in the attack she's going to
testify but the other one and they had
they had the choice of a thousand
Witnesses literally to put on on day one
moment one and they chose a
documentarian who was embedded with the
proud boys you know that that a lot
those are the only two witnesses tonight
so and that's that's that's key because
we actually pulled video at one point
because you know we we actually have
interviewed uh Tasha and Dakota Adams
now to talk Tasha and Dakota Adams is
the estranged wife and a strange son of
Stuart Rhodes the guy with the eye patch
okay
um which is not the proud boys but the
proud boys and The Oath Keepers seem to
be bedfellows here when it comes to the
Insurrection and overturning the
Constitution and making Donald Trump the
dictator and the reason why I say that
is because the proud boys were supposed
to be Roger Stone Security on January 6.
that was the that was the the what
everyone saw is the plan going forward
he appeared with them several times and
then you have the documentary film which
you're talking about and specifically
the part that has been public which is
the part in the parking garage where
Stewart Rhodes the founder of The Oath
Keepers the guy with the eye patch is
meeting with Enrique tario who we know
just recently was charged with uh super
on a superseding indictment with a
seditious conspiracy those two met in a
garage and they talked about I don't
know who knows but what what seems
suspicious from that moment is that the
security or the detail from
Roger Stone switch from the proud boys
to The Oath Keepers and the most
significant part about that to me is
Bryant and Brian ulrich's
um when they uh when the magistrate took
his plea deal that judge asked Brian
Ulrich uh Stewart Rhodes uh Lieutenant
who was protecting Roger Stone that Day
quote unquote protecting he asked that
the magistrate asked Brian Ulrich were
you in a plan with Stuart Rhodes to make
sure there was no peaceful transfer of
power and Brian ulrich's response was
yes sir
um yes that is exactly what we were
trying to do and I think that's
important I think that's important yeah
yeah so so this the reason I asked you
that question was not to set you up like
well I haven't read the Brookings report
Pope so you're right it's because my
take away from having been where you
have been which is at a front row seat
ringside over the last year and trying
to synthesize in real time all of the
new information we get the indictments
the interviews the leaks the documents
the 258 missing minutes from the White
House log you know and trying in real
time what the benefit of the John 6
Committee in the Brooking Institute has
is they can take the plane up ten
thousand feet and they can come up with
it with it with a timeline the reason I
asked you that was because the takeaway
for my reading of the Brookings
Institute and what I think the John 6
committee is going to demonstrate is
that there were basically four legs to
the stool or so for Trump in the
conspiracy to cling to power and it
starts before jansex it even starts
before the election
it is using violence in and and casting
aspersions on the validity and the
um the validity of the election even
before the election even before the
election Trump starts tweeting if I lose
this if I don't win in a landslide it
must have been fraud okay he lights the
fuse there which means he's never going
to accept the legitimate results of the
election and that starts during the
campaign before the election on Election
night he continues with his trolling of
the election that he it must be stolen
from him and this is all dog whistles to
the proud Boys The Oath Keepers and
everybody else who wants to benefit from
Trump being in power so he starts that
before then what does he do then he uses
and this is the people that are going to
be front and center at one in one
session the Department of Justice he
tries to corrupt them in order
to file lawsuits to claim that there was
fraud hold a press conference and claim
that there was fraud go to the Supreme
Court
and claim that there was fraud and when
the people that were in positions of
power first bill Barr then replaced by
Jeff Rosen when he didn't like them
didn't like that they weren't going to
do his bidding he brought in people like
Jeff Clark so don't this is my point
Jeffrey Clark John Eastman Mark Meadows
and Donald Trump were in a a
multi-layered conspiracy John Eastman
was the conspiracy component that dealt
with the fake electors and getting Mike
Pence to overthrow the government he's
in that conspiracy with Trump we can
have overlapping conspiracy circles Jeff
Clark is in conspiracy with Trump to try
to influence from within the Department
of Justice the originally Bill Barr who
left then Jeff Rosen who was the acting
attorney general and and a guy named
Donahue who's the deputy attorney
general Clark even violated Department
of Justice policy by having direct
contact with Donald Trump when he was
not supposed to because he's like five
layers down the totem pole he's supposed
to go to his boss his boss his boss and
his boss's boss's boss to have any
interaction with Trump instead he's
having direct interaction with Trump
trump at one point was going to replace
and threaten to replace Jeff Rosen if
they didn't file the lawsuit at the
Supreme Court level if they didn't hold
the press conference and declared that
there was from the Department of Justice
standpoint fraud he was going to replace
him with Jeff Clark Jeff Clark extorted
the
um the attorney his boss by saying if
you don't send a letter
claiming that there was fraud to these
Battleground States and that you're
looking into it I'll have no choice but
to take the job that Donald Trump is
offering me which is to be your boss by
the way this is in the last week or two
of the presidency right this is after
Bill Barris said nope too much for me
right I don't want to go I don't want to
go to federal prison yeah well he sees
it right now on the wall and he's like I
gotta go yeah this isn't like you know
Jeff Clark you'll be my attorney general
for the next year and a half you'll be
in my attorney general for the next 16
days right all right so you got Jeff
Clark you're going to see a lot of focus
on Jeff Clark on John Eastman on Mark
Meadows so Meadows is on the John's
sixth day of gen six and planning side
right and the aftermath of that John
Eastman is on the let's go after each
state legislature they had a conference
call with 300 state legislators led by
John Eastman attended by Donald Trump in
which they tried to convince them of
what's now been called The Green Bay
sweep by Navarro which is to throw the
entire thing through Mike Pence to the
house where 26 delegations of the House
of by state were controlled by
Republicans meaning Trump would be
re-elected and then when he didn't like
that the fourth leg of the stool When
Donald Trump failed at all of that he
then files all these you know 60 or 70
meritless lawsuits that's led by you
know Giuliani and Sydney Powell and
Jenna he's the Jenna Jenna Ellis that's
over there but that is not going to be
that's interesting but that's not going
to be the focus of the conspiracy that's
going to be laid out I don't think by
the Jan six it's going to be Eastman
Clark Meadows and all those people
around them more like Watergate is what
you're saying because that sounds like
Watergate exactly and what they're going
to use to show criminality and Criminal
Intent is things like hiding evidence
um what 258 missing minutes on the White
House log when Trump is making phone
calls and nothing's being recorded on
January 6th is that the money flush down
the toilet or is that the one he took to
Mar-A-Lago with it that's the one
literally you pull the White House log
and it's blank for the entire inspection
and we know he was making phone calls on
his own phone or burner phones so you
have Criminal Intent demonstrated by
um uh hiding and missing documents lack
of cooperation in the investigation at
all I mean Trump refuses to testify
Meadows refuses to testify everybody
involved refuses to testify now by the
way
Jeffrey Clark I believe did testify
ultimately and if he didn't do you
remember about six months ago Jeff Rosen
and Donahue went in to testify that was
a huge development in the scheme of
everything going on in the in the um
social media you know verse we were like
yeah it happened but it was a big deal
that had happened because they told
everything about what happened with
Donald Trump trying to pressure the
Department of Justice to do his bidding
to cling to power that was a big moment
in the investigation so I so I want to
play the clip
um of The Proud boys of the
documentarian that's going to be one of
the witnesses I want to play that right
here but first I want to ask does any of
this have to do with uh sillion
um actually agreeing to testify maybe at
some of these hearings
this one this doj league that you're
talking about yeah you think that's
gonna produce any results from Rosen or
anything like that because yeah White
House counsel so he would have been in
these meetings when they were saying I'm
going to be attorney general no I'm
going to be attorney general he's the
link he's the link but remember Rosen
and Donahue have already given given up
the goods as to exactly what happened
how they were called on the car Jeff
Rosen was called on the carpet by Donald
Trump
um before Jan six in the in the
Christmas New Year's period and said
Rosen you're this is a quote from Jeff
Rosa Rosen you're not going to do what I
want you to do you're not going to find
fraud right so I'm thinking about
replacing you and I've been told by
other people that Jeff Clark is is
better for the job I mean you could see
Trump saying this that's why this has so
much credibility because none of these
people have any reason to lie against
their own interest at this point
um so you have all of that and then you
have the things that Trump was doing
that we
um commented on at the time but have
taken on new Import in the analysis
which is he had the opportunity to stop
the Insurrection at the time and instead
he tweets gasoline on the fire right
instead of telling them to get off the
Capitol and go home he tells them we
love you you're doing great you know the
fraud that's been perpetrated you're
great Americans and he even does it at
six o'clock after it's it's apparent
that there's been multiple deaths and
injuries on the Capitol and how close
legislators Nancy Pelosi Michael Pence
and others were to being hanged shot
killed dragged down the capitol steps
and everything else and he's still
Tweeting and you know Ivanka Trump and
her testimony where she gave a
deposition testimony about her having
interaction with her father right and
all of those aides senior aides that
none of us even know the name of today
who were all the senior aid for Mike for
Mark Meadows the senior aide for the
Communications Department who are going
to comment about Donald Trump in the
dining room Donald Trump
um not taking any action doing the the
the uh the obverse of taking action
watching it all on Fox news
right exactly right that is another leg
of the stool when he couldn't take it by
lawsuits that had no merit by ordering
his Department of Justice to do
something that had no merit and they
told him it had no merit by filing these
law this meritless um fake elector
scheme what was left blow up the capital
and use the proud Boys The Oath Keepers
to do it well here there was another
part of the conspiracy well here's part
of that documentary and I think we're
going to see more of this uh this
documentary film that they were actually
embedded with
um during some of this hearing but
here's the clip that has been made
public by news4
.
[Music]
he's joined by Stuart Rhodes founder of
The Oath Keepers militia several of his
members have also been arrested and
prosecutors allege some Oath Keepers may
have been planning the attack as early
as November Rhodes himself has not been
arrested
so this was before this this footage
obviously was before
um Stewart was arrested but you see them
there meeting in the parking garage and
I think you're right that was his last
his the martial law you know the
seditious conspiracy this violent thing
because he was setting that up too in
December he kept saying come to the
Capitol help save me please save me if
if they won't save me you will save me
you're that's where the Insurrection is
the last gasp effort right
um but but I want everybody to
understand the connective tissue between
all of these coordinated efforts what
they couldn't take by lawsuits they
couldn't take by Department of Justice
brow beating they couldn't take by the
fake slate of electors that it was let
then he just lit the kerosene fired the
missile and aimed it at the Capitol
right to cling to power I mean it's hard
to believe this I mean I I tweeted I'm
sure you commented on it too you know
the that Woodward and Bernstein got the
band back together again in order to
write an editorial and say this guy
Trump is our first seditious President
right like we owe Nixon an apology yeah
right like this is not we have not seen
anything to this degree or caliber in
our history as a nation and who's better
situated to comment historically on that
than Woodward and Bernstein well they
are that they are the key Gabe you
wanted to say something about the uh
proud Boys video I think yeah so that
video so here's the thing that video uh
I I I feel like there are other people
online who are able to get some clips
but this video that was made by uh
Channel 4 News which is a is a British
um uh station right they had their crew
go in and I just want to point out that
there is a is a theme between all these
people who perform like or who like do
the seditious conspiracy is that they
document it they either go into the
capital and they're working wearing
their workers badges they posted on
social media like check me out I'm in
the capital smearing [ __ ] on the walls
or hey let's get a documentary crew and
let's film all of these people who are
on the [ __ ] list by the FBI and other
agencies that are already being alerted
about their activity to say let's
document every single thing we do and so
I'm kind of very interested because
here's the thing the story behind this
clip that I was able to pull
and get my hands on was a clip that was
later removed
from the news station it's no longer
available on anywhere online or anything
like you'll only be able to find this
clip and maybe two other clips from the
documentary because what I imagine
happened is January 6 committee was like
oh you guys made a documentary about
this you need to pull it immediately no
one else can see this because we need to
show this during our presentation which
will most likely happen tonight or
throughout the the actual uh hearings
you know in the history of History
documentarians being embedded and having
key information is happens more than you
think you know as as you guys probably
know when unfortunately the events of 9
11 were happening there was a French
documentary crew that was following a
fire department and rookies in a fire
department at a fire station right near
the World Trade Center on the day of 9
11. and they went and the footage from
that
is is breathtaking and of course that is
sad but if they weren't there we
wouldn't have the historical record of
you know documentarians doing things
like you know we've seen you know uh
people who've gotten convicted because
of things they've said in a documentary
right it happens a lot well Roger Stone
actually there was another crew
following him during this yeah and that
one is that documentary has yet to be uh
released the Washington Post had an
exclusive where they played some clips
together but he's on the phone and one
of them talking about how we need to
cause all sorts of chaos which is we
need to we need to get funding to talk
about the suitcases with ballots we need
to talk about the ballot boxes we need
to talk about this to sew any sort of
doubt in the election and the results
that came out so Gabe and and Tony the
the other good thing about the uh
Brookings report which we'll see with
the Jan 6 committee is they outline four
major federal crimes that they believe
the evidence supports even looking at
the Brookings Institute even looks at
the possible defenses by Trump
um and and shoots them down and the four
that I want to put on everybody's radar
so they can use it as a lens to analyze
the um the presentation is 18 USC 371
which is a conspiracy to defraud the
government and that would be Trump Clark
and Eastman 18. the one that judge
Carter kind of alluded to in his
decision yeah yeah judge Carter thinks
too if these are the first two I'm going
to mention are right out of Judge Carter
as well second one is 18 USC 1521 which
is conspiracy to impede an official
proceeding and now we're back to Clark
Eastman Trump Meadows Giuliani and all
the rest of the people and then 18 USC
241 which has gotten little press but
it's possible which is a conspiracy to
interfere with voting rights then you've
got the Big Mac Daddy one of them all
which is sedition conspiracy which is 18
USC 2384 which of course people have
been charged with and some have already
pled guilty to mainly Oath Keepers and
proud boys and others but those are the
federal crimes and so the the the your
um your audience some of which are
saying well garland would have already
indicted he's not it's not like Garland
is waiting for this presentation he's
not right he's doing his own he's doing
his own grand jury and there's more than
one grand jury there are at least three
grand juries that we can figure out that
are sitting in Washington that are
listening to various evidence on various
legs of this stool that I identified
there's a grand jury that's listening to
the evidence about the fake electors
there's a which and Navarro kind of got
caught up in that there's a grand jury
that's listening to you know contempt of
congress like Peter Navarro with Bannon
Meadows and those other people you know
and then there's a third one that's
looking at overall the Jan six and the
conspiracies that we've identified pre
and post and so that Jan sixth is a is
one aspect one component one spoke book
of The Conspiracy but it is it is not
all of the conspiracy that started I
think you're going to hear in the Gen 6
presentation back in at election time
even before election time in the
primaries
Trump accused
um made accusations of fraud even though
some of those primaries he won when Ted
Cruz won a Iowa caucus he said Ted Cruz
had committed fraud in the Iowa caucus
so Trump was always going to use
the threat of claiming that the election
was illegitimate even before the
election even started and that just got
all of his people together and then my
last comment and then I'll leave it to
you guys my last comment is why some
people are saying why does this matter
those that want to believe it already
already believe it and those that don't
will never believe it and that is true
but as a republic to hold people
accountable you have to hold hearings
like this you have to do investigations
like this and if and if the only
audience for this besides people like
you and me and your audience and legal
AF is people that really want to arm
themselves with knowledge so that they
can have a good faith First Amendment
debate with their neighbor and others
okay that's one good thing second good
thing is there are Independents out
there right who don't align with either
party who may be swayed for the midterms
or Beyond or when Trump runs again or a
trump accolite like the santis who never
who never
um who never separated himself from this
conspiracy or anything I mean they're
all none of them are covered in glory
all of them are covered all of the GOP
has has genuflected to the idol of
Donald Trump and so my goal in my
analysis in watching is that there is a
presentation that is made that it that
appeals to five percent ten percent
twenty percent whatever it is that
hasn't yet made their decision about
which party to align themselves with
well and I think that's a good point
that that this information may help
Americans decide
um not just about what they think about
that day but what actually happened
right because what you think about what
you believe about that day is different
maybe than the facts and there's one one
other thing I wanted to ask you about
before you leave um on some of this
testimony that the testimony that we may
see in this presentation it was revealed
yesterday that possibly Ivanka Trump and
Jared kushner's testimony to the January
6th select committee would be part of
this presentation which I think is kind
of a significant little leak like you
were saying earlier they keep you know
they drip drip drip some of this stuff
and I think it's to get people to pay
attention
um and we're going to have coverage
beforehand an hour before if they have a
break which they more likely will have a
break in this presentation we'll have
some commentary then and then I I really
want to get your take afterwards at some
point
um if you can join us afterwards
tomorrow
um to make sure because then we'll know
right we'll know what we don't know now
um but the one thing that we don't know
now that I hope we know is some of this
testimony from Ivanka and Jared do you
think that's significant or do you think
that's just kind of the drama of it no I
think it's significant I I've been doing
some reading about both of them she at
least what we've heard from the media
she she's going to be able to testify it
has testified in a sworn deposition
about what Donald Trump was doing
twiddling his thumbs or Worse on Jan 6
and around Jan six and what she tried to
do unsuccessfully the biggest problem in
the New York Times reported it today the
biggest problem is Jared Kushner on the
night of the election
decided that his that his father-in-law
had gone around to bend about election
fraud and he he they let Elvis left the
building right Kushner according to New
York Times reporting Kushner told his
wife
we're moving to Miami this was the night
of the election
so they left the small little kitchen
cabinet of advisors of Donald Trump to
be replaced by the flynns the giuliani's
the Powells the wackadas all the
wackadus while while Kush while Kushner
moved to Miami and then went and got
into bed with the Saudi Arabians to
raise two billion dollars for his fund
well you know he had to make sure his
retirement was set up I'm sure yeah well
you want to be like Navarro eating right
food right right and and having to grift
his legal fees because he doesn't want
to dip into his retirement so what is it
so what does it mean it means that they
on the way out tried to convince I think
their father-in-law and their father
that that he had lost the election and
that did not go over well right and they
headed for the exit and they left a
power vacuum or a vacuum of advisors
around Trump which contributed
to because now he's getting high in his
own Supply surrounded by people that are
just sycophants right they're not going
to tell them the truth that have their
own vested interest in all of this
craziness find the fraud that doesn't
exist he was told
he was told by the heads of the cyber
security unit in charge of of fair
elections for America
a cabinet level position he was told by
his Department of Justice both Barr
Rosen and others he was told by state
legislators he was told by U.S attorneys
in places like Georgia the Battleground
states he was told by federal judges
that there was no fraud in the election
right and yet and yet he continued to
argue it and continue to push buttons
firing missiles in his own way at the
Capitol in order to regain power well
and I I believe that you're right
because a video resurfaced this morning
of an election official in Georgia when
um when all this was happening and this
was on December 1st this was before
um the the Insurrection was even a
thought in the Americans Minds he was
saying the Pres Mr President please stop
you're gonna get someone hurt like he
was sounding the alarm Bells was that
was that the was that the assistant was
that the U.S attorney for Georgia or the
assistant U.S attorney because I know he
commented something simple well no it
was actually an election official um
I actually have the video if you have
just you're right about it you're
totally right I can I can pull this uh
video
um and it's it's it's sort of long but
we can get the uh the gist of it here in
the beginning here here is here's the
press conference that was happening stop
inspiring people to commit potential
acts of violence someone's gonna get
hurt someone's gonna get shot someone's
gonna get killed
and it's not right
yeah I yeah
so that that's that's this who is he the
supervisor of elections uh I think
that's his uh official title uh um yeah
for Georgia
yeah I I
um I'm not finding his official title
here but he worked for Brad rathisperger
who is the Secretary of State I worked
under him in charge of Elections um but
but he goes on to say in this press
conference one of the Dominion workers
who was just hired by Dominion
um the the the Trump people act like
this person was committing fraud that's
where a lot of this Mike Lindell my
pillow stuff comes from this this
conspiracy and the guy the kid was the
kid literally he's a young kid just took
a job with Dominion what he was trying
to do was view a piece of information
that they had to view so he had to move
it from one piece of equipment to
another and they act like because he
moved that file that he was corrupting
it and he was only trying to view the
data that they needed to have listen to
this one this one's in the Brookings
report I'm sure it'll come out in the
Gen 6 committee Clark Jeffrey Clark
writes a memo
two action items like in red letters a
memo to his bosses who are the the
acting attorney general Jeff Rosen and
the deputy attorney general Donahue and
one of the action items is that there is
credible evidence that the Chinese threw
a smart thermostat I'm not making this
up
have somehow influenced the voting
machines and change votes in favor of
Biden along with an attack I mean a
temperature thermostat like like yeah
like the temperature of the [ __ ] room
yes a Honeywell smart thermostat okay
and another allegation that a this poor
company I don't know how they got sucked
into this an Italian Aerospace company
was flipping votes in favor of Biden I I
mean this is how ludicrous and of course
the adults in the room who weren't
corrupt at the Department of Justice
were like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about you're not what are you talking
about and what he wanted what he wanted
what Trump wanted is he wanted the
department of his Department of Justice
as he calls it he wanted them to hold
the press conference the way that the
Attorney General the way the FBI
director held a press conference right
at the last minute of the election for
Hillary to talk about her servers and so
they wanted that October surprise later
on later surprise uh November surprise
press conference for the Department of
Justice officially behind a Podium with
an emblem a seal in front of it says
there was fraud in the election and they
said we can't say that because Mr
President that's that's true right well
you know you know I think uh before you
go I think all this evidence points to
one specific thing in one specific
person obviously Donald Trump knew he
lost he knew he lost and that's why he
started to put these plans into place to
figure out how he could cheat to win how
he could steal democracy away from his
countrymen how he could steal the
election how he could steal our vote and
how he could topple our democracy so he
could subvert being prosecuted because I
really believe that was his fear right
is that he he knew he knew the jig was
up if he wasn't present anymore he was
using the presidency to try to protect
himself from all sorts of things and I
think I think that that jig was going to
be up and he was terrified and the I
think the fact that the manner remains
that he knew he lost but he didn't want
to admit it and he had to keep the big
lie going and they had to do everything
they could everything they could to try
to figure out a way to keep him to be
president
um that way he wouldn't be scrutinized
in federal court state courts his
business be scrutinized which is going
to be eventually and we've seen that
with the January 5th announcement June
uh June or no July 15th announcement and
the one we haven't talked about but that
will that is front and center is fawnee
Willis's special grand jury and some
people in my feed were like what's going
on with that I said it's going to take a
minute right first of all she just got
it and paneled about three months ago
now she she has to conduct her own
interviews they don't just go in and go
pull people off the street she had an
interview 50 to 60 people to find out if
she had a case to present so she had and
documents and subpoenas and tapes and
all of that now she's ready and starting
a week ago she started to bring in
Witnesses and documents to present them
one at a time and it takes a while right
at a grand jury you have a prosecutor
you have evidence you have demonstrative
evidence which is you know slideshows
and and pictures and videos and the
recording of the phone call all over the
11
587 whatever it is votes right and she
has to present this methodically in
order to get the in this case a report
and recommendation because this is not
an indicting grand jury this is a report
and recommendation grand jury back to
fawnee Willis that there's enough
evidence to indict and then she pushes
the button and indicts it's going to
take a month or two to get through this
process it's not going to line up
completely with the Gen 6 committee or
midterms by the way yeah well I I agree
with you I think there's a lot of legs
um as far as grand juries and
indictments not just Federal but
possibly in some of these states uh New
York Georgia being two of them Michael
popock thanks for joining us today and I
can't wait to hear some of your
commentary tonight uh before during and
possibly after I definitely want to get
the after commentary because I want to
hear what your take is from the
information that we actually get from
the history that will be made tonight
the other thing I'm looking forward to
is when speaking of of some of this uh
conspiracy and will Donald Trump ever be
Criminal only charged I really want to
get your take eventually on on this show
after all the hearings are over what
does it look like if Donald Trump is
currently prosecuted do we put a
president in prison and and that sort of
thing so I I hope I hope we maybe we get
more insight into that after these
hearings and as the doj plays out so I'd
like to have you back for that question
specifically no problem other than my
own legal AF podcast with Ben and Karen
this is Mike this is my favorite podcast
oh well thank you I I appreciate that I
appreciate it well go ahead and plug
plug your show because I know I know
you're going to have an episode probably
this weekend uh yeah yeah so so uh
Wednesdays and Saturdays I do a
Wednesday podcast with a former
prosecutor she was the number two
prosecutor in the Manhattan DA's office
which is the model for every Law and
Order episode ever created uh and you
know the home of right now Alvin Bragg
who's who is the current of course
um uh Manhattan D.A and so she's got 30
years experience as a prosecutor she she
and I do a Wednesday show and then I on
Saturday and my Salas who's one of the
founders of Midas Touch and a civil
rights lawyer in his own right he and I
do a longer version we cover about six
or seven
um what we believe are the most
important political legal uh Matters
from that week we cover on our our
weekend edition and our Saturday edition
and we do it a video on YouTube we get
50 60 70 000 YouTube views of what we do
on that week and we then we do uh you
know wherever the major platforms for
podcasts you know we're on all of them
is legal AF so we we um there's
certainly an overlap between you know
one-to-one correlation between your
audience and our audience I know I know
there's a lot of miners buddy here and a
lot of people are saying in the chat
they love the Silver Fox so thank you
thank you for joining me today and and
everyone don't forget to go subscribe to
the mightiest Touch YouTube channel
that's where you'll find legal AF and
you'll find legal AF and all your
directories Apple Spotify Google
anywhere where you download your podcast
you will be able to find the shows on
Wednesday and Saturday Michael popock
we'll see you tonight sir I look forward
to it and you have you have a good rest
your day eat some good lunch because
we're gonna we're gonna need the energy
for tonight good and good luck I you I
told you earlier today yeah I don't envy
you you're you're going to be juggling
you know a dozen commentators right yeah
you know it's no no pressure no pressure
no pressure everyone stick around right
after this break I'll have some
announcements about tonight Michael
popock thank you very much we'll see you
soon everyone stick around we'll be
right back after this break
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you annoyed by masks infringing on
your rights do you wish you didn't have
to comply with Biden's communist mask
mandate are you tired of wearing masks
that actually fit your face well now you
don't have to be introducing the droop
with our patented droop technology every
mask is uniquely molded to not fit your
face just send us a selfie and we'll
have one of our droopers mold the mask
for you elastic free thanks to the truth
I don't even need to pull my mask down
anymore it just sags that way the droop
lets you customize from a selection of
pre-war masks lipstick stains included
make sure to order your droop today Drew
be the spread you want to see in the
world
catch Tony's twitch stream the [ __ ] list
Roundup at twitch.tv slash the Tony
Michaels we're back to the king of
Brilliance this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around with the
break Michael hope the Silver Fox from
legal AF Midas Touch legal podcast on
Wednesdays and Saturdays he's going to
be joining us along with Karen agnipolo
KFA from legal AF and Ben mizellis might
join us for the coverage tonight you're
definitely you're definitely going to
want to join us tonight for the coverage
of of the of the January 6th select
hearing uh tonight is the opening
hearing there's going to be a 90-minute
presentation is the word that we're
getting you're gonna hear some of the
stuff that Pope Hawk was talking about
uh today on the show there in the
hearing so definitely tune in we're
going to be doing an hour in advance so
before the hearing which gabbles down at
eight Eastern we're going to be doing an
hour's worth of coverage we're going to
have the likes of Michael Cohen Michael
popock now Karen ignifolo the mizellis
brothers Gabe Sanchez and myself I'll be
hosting the coverage for Midas Touch on
their YouTube channel so don't forget to
go over to the Midas YouTube channel and
make sure to set a reminder for the link
for the January 6th select hearing the
opening hearing tonight the live
coverage will start at 7 p.m Eastern on
the Midas Touch YouTube channel go find
that link and set your reminder You're
Not Gonna Wanna Miss it we got plenty of
guests
uh to cover for you and you're
definitely going to want to listen to
the commentary we got Texas Paul the
Midas Mighty love Texas Paul we've got
the politics girl Lee McGowan is going
to be over there and that's a favorite
for the Midas Mighty so if your mind is
mighty out there and you want to hear
from politics girl Texas Paul Michael
Cohen Michael popock Karen agnipolo the
mizellis brothers Gabe Sanchez and
myself make sure and we have some other
guests as well but make sure make sure
to go find that link on the Midas Touch
YouTube channel until this evening Folks
at 7 pm Eastern Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon